first off I want to know yeah is the Red
Room becoming a nursery now like a few I
feel a if if they had some stuff in
there like that was for kids and there's
I'd like dual purpose no I don't think
so I don't think it will ever become
that that's good yeah that's a good
thing yeah definitely
do you think I love that you sang in the
movie playing the piano
mhm are you do are you hoping that Paul
McCartney hears it and what what he was
what he will think I know Paul
McCartney's daughters a little bit I
might might see if I can get his
approval that we cut girl might I might
hit them up and see if and see if I can
get opinion from him no I mean like
that's one of my favorite songs and I
was I was hesitant to sing it because
you know it's I did I want to do it
service you know but it's kind of it was
fun to be able to do that and a little
bit nerve-wracking and I sort of didn't
realize they were going to put it on the
soundtrack that was all kind of unused
to me so a little bit shocked when I
heard that but I actually haven't heard
it yet
so I'm sort of trying to avoid it until
I have to hear it how do you think you
know Christian Grey is as a father how
will he be as a father well I think you
know if the idea of him being a father
in the first movie is sort of terrifying
I don't think he feels that I mean even
by the by freed he doesn't feel like
he's ready when he's first told you know
he thinks that because he had a bad
childhood and his parents weren't great
he'd be the same you know and but I
think that Anna and the effect on us
love is hard on him and made him so much
more of a Ryan did person and a better
person a more open person and more
capable person in emotionally I think
you know it's it's probably you know
it's promising you know I don't even
think the way it finishes with you know
both going off with the little boy yeah
I mean here's hoping that he'd be a good
father by the way anyone I'm a I didn't
know if I was gonna be a good father you
just sort of there's no way no matter
what your history is you just hope that
you will be you know
um Dakota said that you would giving her
something on the first movie yeah what
was it
I was maybe looking back it was the
wrong thing it felt right at the time
but I've I got her one of the floggers
from the Red Room and I got in a glass
case with beautiful like mahogany like
casing from glass and a little plaque
the thing that said you know I can't
write had a line from the movie or
whatever it was I don't know why I
expected that she'd take it well her and
I put it up but and then asked her a
while later what did you do the flogger
and she's like I don't know I think it's
in like the garage summer so she trained
it was a Titanic waste of money yeah I'd
already friend so I don't know what what
C's frame that proves is she didn't
frame it by the way I called her right
there I have you know it's Valentine's
Day of course you're I have a couple
Valentine's Day cards I mean if you
could just like give your best Christian
Grey Valentine's version of these okay
okay you make my eyes happy you make my
lips happy you make my heart happy I
could keep heading south but I think you
get the idea
Wow okay no I didn't actually not see
that coming but you know I was
concentrating too much on American
accent okay you're sweeter than candy
prettier than flowers foamy er than beer
I have no idea what the last one means
either but seriously I love you more
than ever happy Valentine's Day I like
which car with you give your wife yeah I
my wife likes beer too so I this one can
I keep it sure thanks you're gonna have
that one I think yeah that one you know
what thanks a lot again
see ya